l'an dernier le cpe du carrefour a dû
réduire ses dépenses d'environ 100 mille
dollars
on a déjà coupé des arts d'un personnel
de soutien on est à l'os dans le
contexte andré milliards s'explique mal
que québec veuille imposer aux réseaux
120 millions de compressions en plus on
investit 1.3 milliards dans mon bar dit
sans être certain du rendement moi je
vous dis 120 millions d'entités enfants
j'en suis certain du rhum dans les cpe
la mauvaise humeur et généralisée on est
face à un cul-de-sac
l'association québécoise des cpe exige
le retrait pur et simple des
compressions de 120 millions et lance
une campagne pour faire plier québec
lettre au député manifestation une série
de moyens de pression qui pourraient
culminer par la fermeture de cpe toutes
les modulations d'interruption de
service que vous pouvez y mettre
imaginez sont possibles sont sur la
planche à dessin que ce soit des
interruptions ponctuelles en terme d'art
ponctuelles en termes de régions ou
encore ultime
une fermeture qui serait national du
grog en éveillant ne put ce cpe de
québec fusionne avec un voisin pour
réduire ses dépenses
on avait déjà économiser 45 mille
dollars l'an dernier en éliminant un
poste d'éducatrice une autre os qui
étaient reçus de 35 heures avant 7h30
oppose éducatrice propose à
l'alimentation qui étaient coupés aussi
de 2h30 semaine l'adjointe
administrations étaient coupés d'une
journée complète
lui aussi pense que de nouvelles
compressions de 120 millions auront un
impact sur les services et le quand les
parents vont faire leur rapport d'impôt
cette année ils vont avoir tout un choc
avec les déductions fédéral une famille
avec un revenu de 85 mille dollars voit
sa facture augmenter de 140 $ par année
mais la somme augmente graduellement un
plus de 2300 $ par enfant pour une
famille avec un revenu de 160 mille
dollars
le ministère de la famille est toujours
déterminé à récupérer c'est 120 millions
$ mais se dit prêt à discuter des moyens
pour y arriver ici d'abidjan télé radio
canada